hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
this is Ravens point apparently this is
just a so I'm just supposed to close my
eyes and stand it's not there
could you not call me Sarah my name is
Mark and it's just really weird kind of
forces Sarah named upon me and I know
ever since your oh I can't read that ooh
okay journal entry Oh journal all right
cool great what's happening my good what
can I get that oh yeah okay I'll take
that
oh no items I just picked up a oh oh no
oh I hate this
oh I hate this oh I hate this uh okay
close my eyes huh that's all I gotta do
well that's easy boy I wish I could look
at that that'd be so great look like a
bunny
that doesn't look like a bunny at all
are you
that is pretty horrifying that if I do
say so myself that is just plain old
horrifying
okay good hey there's the TV from my van
that's great okay so is he hiding right
now am I wasting time to find this thing
by just [ __ ] around take that small
tin can yeah I'll be good from him
that's the best
I'm sorry oh no that was the light oh
that was the thing I was supposed to
turn on
I think hello oh oh hi whoa wait for the
right time ooh did I die
was that the horrible feeling of death
wasn't that bad I guess didn't realize
what was going on I thought that maybe I
had done some good wrong why does the
light turn off whenever I picked that up
that's that's unpleasant okay so I just
gotta wait for the right time then so
will your tone maze I need to let it get
close to me until I hear the laughter
and then I die oh [ __ ] where was that
hello oh you're in the same place that's
that's good oh yeah okay so I'm gonna
stand here and just stand right here not
gonna close my
I hated that I hated that with passion
I hated that very much no how long do I
close my eyes for why why why why why I
thought that eyes could open my eyes and
I thought that I would not be dead but
it turns out I must oh it was my turn -
yeah is all making lots of sense I get
it I'm just as real slow learner yeah
there you are
there you are skills a little biscuit
okay I'm gonna go over here you know I'm
gonna wait cuz you're gonna charge me
like an [ __ ] you make it easy on me
you make it so easy okay
[Music]
hey hey okay all right am I supposed to
wait for the Laffer in my guy just look
at it longingly in its big beautiful
let's play hey that's what I'm doing
oh hi hello okay good great I'm gonna be
right here's good good okay I don't know
if I'm supposed to wait for the laugh
but I think that's what I'm supposed to
do I think I don't know that's good
that's good thing am I supposed to keep
this light on okay hi hi
let me read these okay so I I do have to
wait for the laughter okay the
hilariousness of the situation has to
strike my soul before I can actually
turn off my eyes I need to see the
comedy and lust after it before I can do
such a thing as the like has closed my
eyes
good great I got it's just real narrow
timing just real narrow but I got it
okay God you shouldn't be squatting over
with your back turned oh hi well hi
weird place to be oh [ __ ] close okay
sweet quick this time God good
oh no I unleashed the demon huh
do tell okay well ain't that some
delightful something or other
made by Grom bismil games okay so that
was um interesting very interesting I
liked it a lot definitely scary I don't
like the idea of anything charging at me
and I have to do the timing very closely
but very good
under under what you may be asking well
I'm going to tell you under the ocean
which means that we're going to be under
the ocean thing you're adding two and
two together now 19 well we just can't
decide what year we're gonna randomly 17
a good year I am very happy with that
one does this have anything to do with
the Titanic [ __ ]
another waking up from a dream sequence
come on now how many times have we done
this oh I'm drunk
ooh there we are okay well time to rinse
my face off with super soap
good put my bowl of food on the bed
unless that's a bedpan which means it's
okay cool hello just boo [ __ ] alright
anything back there
no but there's a hole in the wall okay I
don't know about this I feel slightly
uncomfortable under the ship ah or
that's helpful
I'm sure airflow is real good this far
below deck yes
feels good locked to the surgeon study
huh well it doesn't bode too well that
the surgeons on this boat are still
studying I guess life is a life of
learning lifelong learning learning this
okay who's playing games with me or was
that simply the rocking of the motion of
the ocean
all right but if I round that corner and
two people are going at it like monkeys
in a soap sack
I'm gonna be real upset about that whose
[ __ ] oh okay you know for 1917 this
was all of this tune there gonna be some
around this corner Hey okay nothing did
I get the keys to the surgeon study
there is no oh dear Alice today we went
over the top the joy and serenity of
heaven waited us then Alexander
condemned condemned us all we will wait
for him to pay his sins face the devil
and he will flee from you run from the
devil and you are his okay so what
you're telling me is that I shouldn't
run away from anything I see I'm gonna
take that quite literally if there's any
demons they'll want to pop out at me I
ain't gonna run away from you I'm gonna
face you right in your stupid ran away
but I fought it there's what the
feelings hey listen oh okay so it's a
whole lot of nothing is that what you're
saying to me there's a whole lot of
nothing here hmm mr. doctor's cow Oh
was there a mr. doctor in here hey I'm
gonna go down to the surgeon study and
I'm gonna make sure no doctors are been
cowardly
hey can i hello that's a good thing
why no no way
whose flopping around down there it's a
big dick Larry out there ocupado I'm bit
you don't need to try the doctors out
very cowardly yeah I don't think so if I
don't have to I would much rather not
yeah I sure you okay you're just gonna
keep doing that huh okay well the doctor
is out there was no point coming in here
hey I'm gonna face the demon booth there
no one okay not a hundred percent sure
what I'm doing here yeah I hear ya what
am I supposed to do oh [ __ ] oh I can
Crouch oh there's something there how do
i oh I can do [ __ ] no one's here ha ha
ha
no one's anywhere who's knock knocking
on the chamber door what oh oh yes
normal yes that's a whole lot of normal
I don't know what's happening here and I
don't know why [ __ ] a bit of a bad
feeling about it okay stairs you say ok
so those are locked so I need to find
another keys what you're saying that's
what you get ya I'm not running from
nobody I'm gonna face the devil if that
is you mr. tall man oh good more lunch
ah yeah there's good closing doors make
sure there's no flooding spreads no
we're good great crew meal times those
are very strict inquire at lord of
service for service crew times ah the
Lord of service much like the lord of
the dance
hey was there a point to coming in it
Oh is real
Oh our breath reeks of death oh this is
wonderful
hey I like this this is all good stuff
why does my breath reeked of death what
have you been feeding me what have I
been eating exactly okay yeah there was
something behind me I mean there's
something in front of me now laughing
maniacally off in the distance but I
think that's better than something
laughing behind me sort posts and signal
messages before 8:00 p.m. Greenwich Time
okay handle with care
okay all this is super okay very confess
I'm not sure where I'm supposed to go hi
coat ah the stripper pole room great ooh
hello I got keys that's good
hi Hey how are you doing hey what is up
I feel I'm gonna face demon I'm facing
the demons the demons gone
face demon it demon goes bye-bye it's as
simple as that it is as easy and simple
as that now where was the place that I
needed this key oh here we go
[Music]
perfect up again exactly where I needed
to know I needed to go great
anything else looked okay well nothing
oh I'm gonna face you I'm gonna oh wait
a minute wait a minute
hello what happened to you oh well
that's curious huh something tells me
that ain't supposed to happen
Pathfinder's will walk here oh there you
are okay okay oh I'm up what what okay
yeah a big guy I'm just gonna go here
all right here we go
I can't Oh crawling can't crawl crawl
you're tall how once across the cheek
alley so what do I get to do face is
demon how do I do this hi I'm I run I'm
a run in here I should be able to crawl
through here I would think I crawled
through here before you clobbered me
okay what am I gonna do run right
through I'm gonna do that here we go I'm
coming for you yeah don't even think
about it bro ow I have a funny feeling
that I'm supposed to be able to crawl
through that little hole there but it's
just not letting me for some reason yeah
I think it's supposed to go this way but
it's not for some reason I think I'm out
above
alright what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
leave him here Hey come on come here
come here I just want to converse with
you come here yeah it's ready oh yeah ok
yeah come on keep coming
ok keep coming no no no no come all the
way down all the way whoops hey buddy
hey you stupid tall guy lovely lovely
there you go come on oh he doesn't want
to go down ok well problem is how do I
that seems to be a bit of an issue
oh you clobbered my tongue or maybe
occurred ring around the rosy pocket
full of posy ah he catches me on the
backswing I don't think there's a way
around cuz I think you're supposed to be
able to go in here but it just don't let
you go okay I think I might've bug this
one what if I go around like what if I
go down and then all the way around and
back up here technically it's all part
of the same nah the doors closed well
that sucks oh [ __ ] oh whoa hey nice the
helmet dude what's with your tude hey
buddy hey listen listen you need to calm
yourself down yeah once he once he swung
there's no escaping the swung his swung
is too powerful
alright maybe I could in the
pole-dancing room if he comes this way
oh no it I went wrong oh this is wrong
hey dinnertime ding-ding-ding
come get your grub oh he's gonna meet me
right here he's gonna meet me with his
meat hooks I thought it was that oh here
we go whole dancing room hey buddy hey
buddy hey buddy
what's going on buddy oh [ __ ] buddy oh
boy
okay ring-around-the-rosie gonna do a
pole dance for oh no don't Club me I
think this is broken sad to say I think
it's very broken my apologies to the
chef I'm gonna get in here oh yeah
you're supposed to go around there but I
think it's booked okay that's sad so sad
so this is floors two now if you guys
remember a game called scp-087 B it is a
game about infinite stairs and in these
infinite stairs lurk infinite horrors
this game is similar you either go up or
down in this one there's no exit you can
only die apparently somewhere along the
line it starts to get real bad and by
bad I don't mean the game is bad but I
mean bad as in Horrors start appearing
from every whichaway to haunt your
dreams and I run I can run I hope
there's no punishment for running like a
guillotine or a big swinging blade
descending from the ceiling but punish
me for my own carelessness see the thing
about SCP oh wait 7b was that it was
very bad to go sprinting into the
darkness and I have a funny feeling that
it's just as bad to do it here man it is
really infinite ain't it I'm not sure if
there's like gonna be doors or something
or offshoot hallways or hoses I do
notice I have a health bar and I usually
entails there some dangers lurking by
every corner okay either I'm crazy or
something's gonna happen at some point
there's got to be something right it's
not just a game with absolutely nothing
and it's leaves me here to be paranoid
about what the hell's lurking behind
every corner this is great it was good
it was good I feel comfortable about
this also it's very toasty in this room
at the moment I haven't sorted out the
air conditioning problem yet but that's
besides the point because I'm on floor
14 and I don't know why nothing's
happening is there really nothing I got
this like sense of dread that at any
moment something's gonna pop out behind
a corner which is weird cuz there's
nothing really saying that's gonna
happen but it just seems like there
should have been something by now unless
I'm doing some horribly wrong [ __ ] oh hi
good are you kidding me what what are
you doing why is that a thing
why Oh what pardon me that just random
why is there another number next to the
number of the floor that it is is that
just because I finally got something to
do something and then that's when the
real counter starts is as I wait where'd
who oh hi oh oh hi um reruns ready okay
I guess I got that one that's fine okay
weird uh mr. red eyes okay you need
clear eyes to fix your red dry ah good
okay well if it's the same thing of whoo
hey Dodge well if it's the same thing
over and over again I think I think I
can handle that it just depends on if
it's gonna change to something else and
then I won't know how to deal with that
okay you zoom it's good thing I'm so
fast it looks like I can go real fast if
I use the strafe method which is using
the
and sideways to go wrap around these
corners a little quicker and it seems to
be working like the tighter I make this
probably the quicker it's gonna end up
being whoo okay so they're they're not
too much of a problem the surprise
element is over about that one great
great great so far so good I mean I made
it to floor 42 yes oh wait no something
hit me my HP is down when did I HP get
down why because I was cutting it too
close to the data meter all right what's
going on and missed me okay well I think
I won I'm not sure what winning means in
this game but I think I won is it just
the same thing over and over again is
that really all we got here same thing
over and over again it's so close that
whoa jeez that was loud okay why was
that loud touched me it touched me with
his gross body oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay well that's weird okay I didn't
know you're gonna throw more at me man
well that's that's oh hi Oh shooty duty
okay well that's problem okay so your
answer to the question is just to throw
throw many much more enemies at me throw
many much more enemies all right cool
good I can do with that for the love of
the meme let me get to floor 69 that's
all I want is one floor 69 please no oh
wow you ran very close I want to get to
floor see if I don't get to floor 69 I'm
gonna be sorely disappointed okay around
and out okay good come on just four more
floors floor 69 please please oh oh you
guys didn't even have eyes did they not
have eyes or was that crazy about that
I'm not Arabs enter okay
[Applause]
okay they must have had eyes and I must
be crazy okay well now I've gotten my
goal so I guess all I ever wanted to
accomplish in life has been accomplished
hey you're getting just getting louder
just getting louder Madhu do game over
alright well that was a bit that's a bit
dumb alright cool what happens if you go
down probably the same thing but
whatever yeah nothing's gonna change
it's the same thing yes same thing okay
so that was um that was not so bad but
not great yeah oh it's not so bad so I'm
gonna play one more game because I'm
gonna count those two or just one okay
so this one says it is a short meta
horror game I don't know what that means
but I gotta do some work apparently
la dee dee dee da da da da oh la dee dee
dee done and her password Dick password
okay I don't know my own password um
okay
Oh what what wait what am i what up what
am i doing oh I can't read that
that is rah rah SFX - okay brah whose if
I'm not zombies okay good hey a boat
my name is markiplier and welcome to
plug-and-play the reason oh wait oh what
the [ __ ]
wait those are my vut wait a minute wait
a minute
those are my videos it's not just
playing them off the internet these are
literally my videos well I don't like
that at all that that's no good oh well
[ __ ] it crashed wait I saw that excuse
excuse me excuse me who was in here wait
a minute what the wait now open her up
oh okay alright bookshelf okay okay
let's try this again it crashed but okay
mm-hmm you see them everywhere now and
don't really give it a second thought as
it used tracking cookies to track your
browsing history and personal profile
provide suggestions that might appeal to
you you know the way Amazon suggests new
books based on what you just read or
when you search for something on Google
and then start seeing ask for it
everywhere or when you're a
twenty-something year old girl in a
relationship on Facebook and suddenly
all your ads for engagement rings and
wedding planets the point is we're all
so used to this that we don't really pay
attention to it anymore but lately these
targeted ads have been unnerving Leon
Point my plastic sheeting in bulk
collect your chain saws on sale
affordable dry lime overnight shipping
available I don't know how they're doing
it I don't know what technology is
driving these changes but somehow it's
like the Internet is reading my mind
showing me ask for things that it
couldn't possibly know I wanted I swear
to God I didn't touch a keyboard I
didn't do a search and I was so careful
to keep all my plans and research and
ideas offline how's it doing this how
does it know about the bodies
mark mark and Mark penis bra bra bra bra
Rui Rui if you're a youtuber consider
clothing through the window as soon as
possible or press the pause button twice
right so this is all files you're just
gonna get a lot of weird sound effects
child goes missing bra I don't know how
to make fake news news I'm gonna promote
my game here the apartment 3 it was a
bad game alright you have to play my
game I'll let you play my game if you
can complete your work today you can't
refuse okay good okay cool um I don't
know what's going on I'm taking a tinkle
that's what's going on I get it now this
game makes sense I understand this fully
an directly yeah there we go it's just
got a shake two shakes no more than that
or you're just playing with yourself oh
that's nice dork where is it where is it
let me lick it
oh god I'm never gonna be able to give
the lights back on momoka got it okay so
I'm gonna go to creepypasta dot-com /
intuitive advertising okay so this is
what we got
intuitive advertising you see him
everywhere oh oh I know what that is
that's what was just here copy and paste
the draft from your notepad
oh I know what it wants oh I get it
Oh what did I do okay I broke that [ __ ]
all right what's this oh that is broken
oh [ __ ] oh god well that's what I get
for not going to the bathroom
when I needed to okay okay we're locked
in huh okay good done let me get some
work done
kit there there we go here we go okay
check your IRL desktop for a folder if
there's no folder on your desktop check
games directory for a folder name puzzle
all right up play your game all right
puzzle here we go okay all right so hint
what do we got the password is in base64
format you got a decode at Google might
help you okay and two if you're dumb and
can't Google a 64 decode here's the last
hint for you okay mjq this ain't the
password read the hints and figure it
out for yourself cool so I got a go
decode base64 cool there we go decode
got the password put this right here and
the passwords that boom got it I'm smart
brain equals big there we go read me
move the brain filed of the game's
directory and return to the game oh yeah
this is big brain time return to the
alright cool here we go go oh oh I need
to get out of here
and how do I do that I asked I asked Oh
God
all my in the back rooms oh god I'm in
the back crumbs I'm in the back rooms
what in the what in the tits is this
what is this overlapping crap was
insanity what the hell I am in the back
rooms this is the these are the the back
rooms these are the back east of back
rooms I've never been more back in more
room oh hi pup how are you doing there
bub good to see you good so you could
see anyway you garden this good good
yeah that's locked okay good great what
is happening Oh reality is intersecting
in a million ways that's not this exit
that's some other exit that's not what
I'm oh god I've lost okay there we go
cafeteria oh okay
well can't go in there that's that don't
work and that's a dead end I think I'm
pretty sure it's hard to tell anymore
what's real and what is not real oh wait
is that mine is that what I did but on a
doll that's what that is daddy you were
a problem the whole time
okay well I am fine oh hi hello okay I
guess I gotta get out of here then all
right cool good I'm gonna get out of
here then all right good okay so you're
stalking behind me and I don't like that
all right cool booty 2d there was a ha
okay so let me go up Eva stairs II
because I have a funny I have a
funkalicious feeling that that actually
is part of the way to go
okay good here's good I can't see [ __ ]
there we go okay good I'm in this place
now wherever that thing is going it just
saw the exit okay so there's an open
door the oh [ __ ] okay
Oh where's it going it's going up some
stairs but that's not where I am that is
somewhere else
it would just went up those stairs which
means that's the exit but I don't know
if I can actually go out the exit I need
five course I need to find a key for the
door I don't like that at all is it
going down the stairs it's going down
the stairs okay so it's going down those
stairs so I got to find a key where the
Frick is he gonna be I don't even know
what the Keys gonna look like okay so
it's about to go by that door there if
I'm right about this yep there she is
okay so what are you guarding in there
there's something in there that I need
to know about Oh as a hammer I don't
know what to do with a hammer it's not
exactly a key but it could be a key
maybe this is the key
hey buh-bye are you doing it alright so
now it's going through those offices and
ODS and they're okay it's right there
it's going in there oh whoa whoa why did
you see me marg Murg maybe this Hammers
gonna pry off the do or the things okay
well I removed the planks that's part of
the problem where's the key so another
issue I have is if I go up here I am
gonna be stuck if it comes back up here
again so if I come up here I better find
a key and fast okay so it is a dead end
here there's no key on the ground
there's nothing over here so this is
just a dead end there's nothing up here
so there's no point in even being up
here oh so warm in here
so warm oh god says short you said this
was a short game this is just a big old
pain in the dick oh how long are you
gonna be going through that okay fine
screw it I'm gonna look in the I don't
think it's in here it's not in here so
maybe there's a key somewhere around in
here I don't know if it's gonna be like
on a desk or something okay it's finally
going back up the stairs I can't see
anything okay so it just went back up
the stairs that's good to know
oh yeah there you are all right cool
good hey how you doing so I'm willing to
bet that it's in like the first area
look I can't find anything
oh I'm roasting alive so it's gonna go
out the other side door is gonna make
its way down to the exit it's just a
long long patrol path it's a really long
patrol path and I don't know what I'm
looking for
oh [ __ ] okay that was duh I didn't think
you were gonna be coming this way so
don't kill me I have no idea what to do
about this
I think that the the key is definitely
somewhere it might be up there still I
don't know it's just it's a very
peculiar system but you know it's just
like there's nothing I can do man it's
just very slow it's an interesting
concept but it's also very annoying is
the main problem that I have with it
it's we won't even let me get it okay so
I'm just gonna bail out of that one cuz
it hurts my eyes after a while so it's
like it's not a bad concept I like the
meta style of things I really do I like
that idea for horror games but in this
one the execution is just a little bit
of laud because it's too sloped too
clunky and not fun see it's not even
scary like I like the concepts of the
back rooms I don't think it's like the
best creepypasta ever I don't know why
it's caught on so hard as it has but at
the same time like I don't think it's
like a back rooms thing but the style is
there it's got some potential but it
also has a lot of flaws that are drawing
it back so anyway that'll do for this
episode of three scary games thank you
everybody so much for watching if you've
got more scary games that you want me to
play let me know down comes below thanks
again and check out more scary games
that I've got down in the description or
over there in the suggestion feed it and
as always see
you video bye
[Music]